I want to start today talking about
Florida and yeah in a certain sense this
is a story about Ron DeSantis but it is
really a story about Ron DeSantis as
Governor not Ron DeSantis as the maybe
future failed Republican presidential
primary candidate Ron DeSantis who still
as of this moment has not announced that
he is running against Donald Trump in
that Republican primary I want to show
you the texture of the right wing
hellscape that DeSantis is rapidly
transforming Florida into now full
disclosure I know people will email me
but David you say these things about
Florida and then you go to Florida okay
I also said things that are terrible
about Donald Trump and I lived in the
United States when Trump was President
so uh yes there are parts of Florida
that I think are great even though they
have infrastructure problems as a result
of of Ron DeSantis and right-wing State
policy those liberal parts of Florida
with the good restaurants as Alex Jones
would say
uh yeah I frequently go there and I
don't understand how that devalues in
any way the criticism of the policy that
the scientist has put in place so CNN
recently had this uh list that they put
up let's take a look at it in recent
times Ron DeSantis has signed a six-week
abortion ban ended concealed weapons
permits the requirement for such permits
ban gender affirming care for Trans
youth restricted drag shows expanded the
don't say gay law blocked and uh an
advanced placement African-American
studies curriculum class and prohibited
vaccine mandates first of I I am going
to make two arguments to you here first
argument all of these bills and laws are
terrible ideas and number two many of
them also directly contradict the stated
values of low government intervention
little government and involvement
freedom and liberty that they claim to
espouse so let's go through some of
these six-week abortion ban DeSantis
signed that in a closed door ceremony I
believe it was last month the bill
prohibits Physicians from performing
abortions after six weeks into a
pregnancy in most cases as I've
explained before
many women
don't even know they're pregnant until
the six week Mark because when you've
missed your period
if you are pregnant you're basically
five weeks pregnant four five depending
on who you ask or you know the the
particulars of that so
it is completely unrealistic absolutely
unreasonable and it is close to a full
abortion ban It also says that if you
want an exception because you've been
raped you have to provide evidence of
the rape
okay uh if it's the result of incest or
human trafficking you need to provide
evidence and that only gets you an
exception up to 15 weeks this is if Roe
v Wade were still in place it would
blatantly violate Roe v Wade it's
another attempt to control women's
bodies and limit choices and it is
insane government overreach we have the
bill that lets you concealed carry
without a permit okay DeSantis signed
this also last month this allows gun
owners to carry firearms in public
without any additional permitting or
training required and it also ends the
state requirement that when you leave
your home with a concealed weapon you
must have special training not even
special just training I think is what we
would call it it's a gift to the gun
lobby it's a gift to the NRA it's a gift
to the more guns and more places and it
will make Florida less safe it will make
Florida more prone to gun violence and
accidents we then have this package of
five bills that were passed
uh and signed into law by Ron DeSantis
and here we are talking about
um a lot of bills that relate directly
to the rights of the LGBT community and
here we're talking about a ban on gender
affirming care for Trans youth this will
prevent doctors from providing hormone
therapy or surgery to minors who
identify as trans You could argue that
it is a form of denial of medical care
that you're just you're taking away
medical freedom because what we're
talking about here is saying hey here's
people who may need certain Services as
determined by medical professionals
instead you have some Republican
lawmakers saying you're not going to be
allowed to do it restrictions on drag
shows this is a law that will prohibit
any establishment that serves alcohol
from hosting performances by drag queens
or drag Kings you can argue that this is
discrimination against a form of
artistic expression you can argue this
violates Free Speech because at the end
of the day we're not talking about
grooming or pedophilia or sexual assault
or any of the things that they love to
say are inextricable uh from drag shows
it's a form of expression and it's a
government Banning that we will see what
happens there's the expansion of don't
say gay don't say gay prohibits teachers
from discussing sexual orientation or
gender identity except does it are you
allowed to say as a female teacher oh my
male husband well that is a discussion
of gender identity but that's not banned
because we know what the real point of
it is it's to censor a and silence LGBT
voices experiences and the reality that
uh all sorts of different types of
people exist in our society and culture
there's the bill
um in addition to this which we talked
about before that blocks the advanced
placement African-American studies class
from being offered in public schools
remember they framed it as they are
forcing this indoctrination onto our
children it's an optional class in my
experience uh it's not as though
advanced placement classes
are exactly super popular I mean that
you know they often feel but what I mean
is it's not like the entire school is
even looking to take these classes it's
a whitewashing of History it denies many
of the struggles of black Americans and
we've talked about it before and then
lastly a bill that bans any vaccine
mandates by any entity in Florida that
includes businesses Schools and
Government agencies now whatever your
feelings are about a coveted vaccine
requirement and I'm there with you if
indeed the coveted vaccine doesn't
prevent transmission there is a case to
say it shouldn't be required the counter
would be if it reduces the chance of
hospitalization and death
for military Readiness it certainly
seems like it could make a difference
but my point is step back from the covet
vaccine
think about how Reckless and
irresponsible it is to say you can't
have any vaccine requirements that you
can't have any vaccine mandates when we
have so many vaccines that do prevent
transmission and are quite literally
Public Health uh godsends there's
probably some better word I could use
that's less religiously uh uh oriented
these are bills that are harmful to
Floridians but they're also harmful to
democracy and many of them run directly
counter to the stated values that these
Republicans claim to espouse which is
they say freedom Liberty do whatever you
want government only involved when
absolutely necessary freedom of speech
freedom of expression except well no
drag shows and no doctors and patients
deciding what's best for them and all
these other things the takeaway is their
principles evaporate as soon as they
conflict with the political reality that
they are trying to fight
one of our sponsors today is wild Health
founded by two Emergency Room Physicians
wild Health takes your genetics and your
Biometrics and your lifestyle data to
really tailor suggestions to your exact
needs in terms of nutrition and exercise
and sleep and supplements and all of
those things and the whole idea is just
for you to function at your best it's
really a quite it's a simple goal but
it's a complex goal to achieve you might
have a specific Health goal you want to
sleep better you want to lose weight you
want to stay healthy and just feel good
wild health will tailor a care plan with
lifestyle interventions instead of
medications which I prefer as an
approach wild health will pair you with
a care team that includes a
board-certified Precision medicine
physician and accredited health coach
who can receive messages from you
anytime through the app it's fully
virtual telemedicine and if you're
really trying to reach your top physical
and mental condition try wild Health's
premium program at wildhealth.com
premium which includes the white glove
concierge service unlimited visits even
higher touch care these results are
really compelling patients have seen
improvements to diabetic markers reduced
risk of cardiovascular disease reduction
in inflammation and more go to
wildhealth.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for 20 off the link is down below